the demolition of two empty station
casino properties officially underway
station announced that they were being
torn down a few months ago but now
locals are having mixed emotions as they
watch them being demolished madison
kimbrough joins us now live from texas
station on rancho and lake mead with
their reaction
a big day for station casinos as
you can see the casino right here texas
station along with fiesta henderson have
been up for decades but now they are
being demolished and will soon be turned
into something new but locals in the
area not too happy about it
i'm upset about it because i used to go
there every weekend and go gambling
there every other day
so a lot of people are upset about it
we're going to miss it truly it's
official
both texas station and fiesta henderson
are being torn down earlier this summer
station casinos announced plans to
demolish both of them along with the
fiesta rancho all three properties will
be sold to other developers the first
two demolitions started monday morning
after getting the proper permits and
many who live near texas station feel
like the need is still there for the
community to have these casinos as it
was more than just a place to gamble but
a family-friendly environment for the
kids it's going to hurt the families
that's what i think we got the skating
and you know it's just a lot for kids to
do that's the only thing the kids have
to do around here as for fiesta rancho
the demolition process has not yet taken
place but for those in the area the hope
is that something community-based will
be put in its place and i'm sad that
it's getting demolished i'm sorry that
uh you know the pandemic i'm pretty sure
is the reason why they're getting
demolished they kind of keep it up maybe
like a little
like area like playground like a park a
nice park you know something nice
because all these parks are just just
filled it doesn't have nothing
extra to it you know so like maybe like
a really nice park or something would be
cool
and last week station casinos announced
that they would also tear down the wild
wild west gambling hall and hotel near
15 and tropicana with plans of
redevelopment reporting live near rancho
in lake mead madison kimbrough 8 news
now